[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
DEAN KARNAZES: Thank you.
And let me let me start
by asking how many of you
ran the marathon yesterday?
And how many of you did not want
to get out of bed this morning?
[LAUGHTER]
It was warm out
there, wasn't it?
I mean for London, yeah.
I saw a lot of
people struggling.
But it was glorious.
So, what I am.
I've run marathons.
But I also run what are
called ultra-marathons.
And in Latin,
ultra means beyond.
So an ultra-marathon is
anything beyond a marathon.
And a marathon-- for
us marathoners know--
is 26.2 miles.
Never used to be that way.
And I'll explain why.
But right now, since 1908, the
distance has been 26.2 miles.
So the people that
had their hands
raised, they ran that
distance yesterday.
So congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'll tell you that
this is a show called
"The David Letterman Show."
And it was filmed
in New York City.
I got a request to be
on David Letterman.
And the thought
of being on stage
with a celebrity like that
was so intimidating to me.
It was overwhelming.
But I thought, you have
two weeks before you're
due to be on the show.
And in that two-week
time frame, they'll
probably give you
extensive media training.
There will be dry runs.
They'll let you know
the questions David
will be asking in advance.
And they'll help me
prepare the answers.
Well, a week goes by, I
haven't heard from anyone.
Two weeks go by,
and all of a sudden,
I found myself on an airplane
from San Francisco, my home
city, to New York City.
And they pick me
up at the airport.
And they kind of whisk me
around in this sleep-deprived,
jet-lagged state.
And then at 6 o'clock
at night, they
bring me to the back entrance
of the Letterman Studio.
And they take me up this thing
they were calling the Green
Room, which was beige.
And they put me in this room.
And they say, sit down Dean.
Sit on the couch.
Relax, have some food.
And I'm not so relaxed.
I'm thinking, the training,
the briefings, the dry run--
when are we going to
get all these things?
And then eventually two of
David's-- what they call
handlers-- walk in the room.
And these handlers
sit down with me.
And they say OK, Dean,
here's what you've got to do.
When you're on the show tonight,
don't make any reference
to it being Monday night,
because your segment is going
to air on Wednesday night.
I said, well, OK.
I can do that.
What's next?
And they said, that's about it.
And they walked out.
And now I'm in there
kind of looking
at my watch freaking
out, thinking
the training, the dry run.
And then two more
people come in.
And they ask me to stand up.
So I stand up.
And like any runner does, I
start shaking my limbs loose
for the big training program.
And these two people, they
kind of look me up and down.
One rubs his chin,
looks at the other one.
They say, yeah, the
guy looks fine to me.
And they walked out.
I don't know who they were.
And now, I'm just really,
really anxiety-ridden.
I'm thinking, the
training, the dry run.
I hear on the loudspeaker,
ultra-marathon man,
we need you at stage
level immediately.
And this door swings open.
And there's a guy
standing there.
And he walks me down this
stark, white hallway--
this nondescript hallway
with these fluorescent lights
overhead.
And we get in a
freight elevator.
We go down a couple of stories.
The door opens, there's
another guy standing there.
The first guy hands
me to the second guy.
The second guy kind of
parades me around a corner.
And there's a third guy.
And I notice the third
guy has a headset on.
And when he sees me
walking towards him,
he says three, two,
one, you're on.
I'm like, what?
And he said, go.
Everyone's waiting for you.
So I kind of stamber out.
I'm not sure what to expect.
And I come around
the corner and wham,
I'm just blinded by these
huge, white stage lights.
I can't see anything
but this fog of white.
And I hear laughter
and applause.
It was like I was in heaven.
I'm sitting there frozen
like a deer in the headlamps.
And I looked to my left, and
there was David Letterman,
with his hand outstretched.
And it's funny.
I wasn't supposed to run out.
I was supposed to just sit
there as the segment ended.
But they didn't really tell me.
So I have this motto--
when all else fails, get
up and start running.
So I just got up and
ran out of the studio.
But anyway, that tells you
a little bit about who I am.
That was 10 years ago when
my first book came out.
10 years later, I
haven't really stopped
running since that point.
And the story I'm
going to tell you
today is about the
origins of the marathon.
So this is my fourth book.
And I think in a lot of
ways, my most personal book,
because I'm 100% Greek.
And my dad has always insisted
we're from the same village
in the mountains of
Greece as Pheidippides,
or Phee-dee-pee-dees,
the famous Greek runner.
I always tell him,
Dad, I grew up in LA.
What village in Greece
are you referring to?
It was a very fascinating
journey to go down.
And I think I'll share
it with you today.
I think that's why I'm here.
You probably are
thinking that you're
listening to Dean Karnazes
speaking, correct?
My name is actually
Constantine Nicholas Karnazes.
So that gives you some
indication I'm Irish.
But how many of you
marathoners, especially,
know the definition
of the word marathon?
Probably you have
an idea, right?
I think most people would
define a marathon as anything
of excruciatingly long
duration, like marathon
sessions of Congress--
or parliament here-- or
marathon traffic jams.
But a marathoner will tell
you what is a marathon.
It's a foot race of
26.2 miles, correct?
And that's the definition.
The actual definition is
field filled with fennel--
fennel the wild herb.
And the reason being
is that in 490 BCE,
the Persians invaded Greece.
And they landed at
this coastal plain
that was covered in wild fennel,
which grows all over Greece--
hence, marathon.
So when people say--
they have those
bumper stickers that
say 26.2, they should
actually read fennel,
because that's the definition
of the word marathon.
We also know the story of
this gentleman, Pheidippides,
that supposedly ran from
the battlefield of Marathon
to the Acropolis after
the Athenians somehow
defeated the Persians.
That distance is 24.8 miles.
And I'll get to that later on.
But he ran 24.8 miles to the
Acropolis proclaimed niki,
niki--
or victory, victory, nike, nike.
We're victorious.
And then what happened to him?
He died, right?
Yeah, he died.
But there's more to
the story than that.
He was actually a
class of citizen
known as a hemerodromoi,
which meant day-long runner.
He was a professional
foot messenger.
And the Greeks realized that
in the mountainous terrain
of southern Greece, a
trained hemerodromoi
could outrun a horse.
And I know this to be true,
because I've actually raced
a horse over a
100 mile foot race
in the mountains of Vermont.
And I beat the horse.
So there's some debate
about the actual translation
of his name, Pheidippides,
meaning spare the horse,
presumably because a
trained runner could not
kill off a horse.
We'll send a runner instead.
I was fascinated
with this story.
And I wanted to
learn more about it.
But the first thing I
wanted to learn is what must
it felt like running in that
costume that he's wearing?
So I visited a
Hollywood costume store.
And I was outfitted with
the hoplite running suit.
And I decided I would tackle
the Silicon Valley marathon.
And I will tell you,
after doing that, I
think I know why he died.
There was some chafing.
There was blistering
where the sun don't shine.
And I also ran barefoot.
And only about
half of that course
was on man-made,
natural dirt surfaces.
The rest was on the
road, as you see here.
So my feet were pretty beat up.
I did see a gentleman
running barefoot yesterday
in the marathon as well.
And he was in the medical tent.
So I don't think
his journey ended
with a medal around his
neck, unfortunately.
But running barefoot,
especially on man-made surfaces,
is very difficult. After
this, I completed this race.
And I thought, OK, I did
everything Pheidippides did.
I'm one with my ancient brother.
But I learned something.
I was on a webinar
with a gentleman
by the name of Professor
Paul Cartledge from Cambridge
University.
And Dr. Cartledge explained
to me that what he did
was actually go much
further than just running
from marathon to the Acropolis.
The historical record says
that when the Persians invaded
the Athenians, they realized
they were badly outnumbered.
And they were going
to be slaughtered.
So they needed reinforcements.
And if you know anything
about ancient Greece
or if you've seen the movie 300,
who's the most bad ass fighting
force in ancient Greece?
The Spartans-- you
know, this is Sparta.
So they dispatched Pheidippides
to run from Athens to Sparta.
And that distance is 153 miles.
So it's much further
than the distance
from Marathon to the Acropolis.
I also learned that
there is a modern day
incarnation of that race
called the Spartathlon.
And it basically follows the
footsteps of Pheidippides
from Athens to Sparta.
So I signed up to do this race.
And this is what the
starting line looks like.
We're at the base of
the Acropolis there.
And there were 350 runners
in the race that year.
There were 47 different
countries represented.
And it's the most elite of
the elite ultra-marathons.
It's very hard to gain
entrance to actually be
able to compete in this race.
You can see some of the
terrain here is beautiful.
But it's very, very mountainous.
The race is also held in
September in southern Greece.
So it's very, very
hot and humid.
Another thing that makes
this race so difficult
is that it tries to stay
within the historical record
of milestones that Herodotus,
the father of history,
recorded Pheidippides being at
certain points during his run.
You have to be at a
city called Corinth,
which is 50.22 miles
from the start,
within 9 and 1/2 hours of the
starting gun going off, or else
you're eliminated from the race.
And those of you that
know marathoning, that's
two back-to-back marathons
in very hot mountainous
conditions, each of those
being around a 4 and 1/2 hour
marathon-- or sub
4 and 1/2 hours.
And the thing is, you don't want
to be there anywhere close to 9
and 1/2 hours because those
aggressive cut-offs continue
the entire duration.
What they have is this thing
they call the death bus.
And it drives along as a sweep.
And anyone that doesn't
make the cut off
has to get into this bus.
And I heard the
bus was horrible.
I heard there's moaning
and groaning in there.
There's blisters.
And it doesn't smell very good.
So I thought, just stay
ahead of these cutoff times,
because you do not want
to get in this bus.
The other thing
with this race is
that you have to complete
it within 36 hours,
because the historical
record from Herodotus
says that Pheidippides
arrived in Sparta the day
after setting out, which can
be interpreted as he left one
morning, got there by
sunset the next day.
One thing I wanted to do in
taking on the Spartathlon
is only wanted to use those
foods the ancient hemerodromoi
had access to when they were
running 2,500 years ago.
So I hate olives, figs.
This is cured meat--
kind of a beef jerky.
And something they call pasteli,
which is a ground sesame seed
honey paste.
I also only drink water,
no electrolyte replenish
or sports beverages to
try to reproduce what
he might have gone through.
There are eight stations
set up along the way.
And I thought it was
really very Greek
that a lot of the volunteers
were having a hard time
supporting their
families, because
of the economic
situation in Greece.
Yet they'd come out and
support all of us runners
as we're running
down their streets.
They had pitchers of
water that you could--
like yesterday-- where you
could kind of sponge off.
Unfortunately, the
water was warm.
There's no ice.
So it's almost like a sauna.
It was almost deleterious
to put the water on you.
But I just felt
kind of obligated,
because they were
there servicing us.
Another thing that
really surprised me
during the Spartathlon was even
though there were 350 of us
at the start, the field
spreads out very quickly.
So I ran, I would say,
over 80% of that 153 miles
all by myself.
When you run 153 miles,
how many days does it take?
Where are the hotels?
Where do you sleep?
The answer is you don't.
You just keep
running for 36 hours
straight through the night.
You just put on a headlamp,
and you keep going.
That checkpoint I was running
into was about mile 115.
And I was refueling
here on some more figs.
So at this point, I'd been
eating figs for about 17 hours.
And right when I
left that checkpoint,
I was going to scale something
called Mount Parthenion.
And if you see, this is an
altitude profile of a course.
So this is looking at
what you've got to climb.
The red line below is
the Boston Marathon--
Heartbreak Hill they call it.
Super--
So I ran Boston
Marathon the Monday
before the London Marathon.
And I'll tell you, Heartbreak
Hill felt like a speed bump
to me after climbing
Mount Parthenion.
So it's a 3,000 foot climb
in about a two mile stretch.
And that's the equivalent
of about three Empire State
buildings straight
up into the sky.
It's 15 mile stretch from one
side to the next checkpoint.
And in those 15 hours-- this is
as I came down the far side--
in 15 miles, it took me five
hours to cover 15 miles.
And I was moving as
quickly as I could.
My heart rate was almost maxed
for that entire five hours.
And all I covered
in that duration
was 15 miles, because
it was so treacherous
up on this mountain.
And here's a view as the night
turned to day the next morning.
You can see the mountain
in the background.
The one unique thing with
the Spartathlon in that it's
like no other race on earth.
Because there's no finish line.
How many of you have done a race
where there's no finish line?
You run with a timing chip.
And you're going
across timing mats
so they're recording
your time the entire way.
But in the main square of
Sparta is this towering bronze
statue of King Leonidas--
the King-- "This is Sparta!"
And what you do to
finish this race
is you run up to
the King's feet--
this bronze statue--
and you touch his feet.
And when you touch his
feet, they stop the clock.
And your race is done.
So here's a shot of me touching
his feet at the very finish.
It's a hugely
emotional moment that's
standing below, because
you've been out there just
battling the elements, battling
yourself, battling your mind.
And when you get to Sparta,
it's such a beautiful moment.
And every single runner I saw
touch his feet, you just melt.
You get the chills.
And it was just an
incredible experience.
Here's another perspective.
After the race, there's a
mandatory medical check.
And I've never seen--
I've been to a lot of medical
checks at the end of races--
I've never seen anything
like this place.
There were more IV bags in
there than grapes on a vine.
People had broken their legs.
They were in splints.
It was really quite
a traumatic scene.
But I checked out just fine.
And having explored this area
a bit and knowing Greece,
I knew that what do you do after
a race like this in Greece?
It's Greece, right?
Why am I running 153 miles
through the mountains?
Go to the beach.
So I hit the coastline
right after that.
And that is the US
cover of my book.
So you've got the UK cover,
which I think is a much--
if you have a book in front
of you, look at the covers.
Which one do you prefer?
AUDIENCE: US.
DEAN KARNAZES: US?
Oh no.
My publisher is here.
But I think I'll
end by explaining
why the marathon is not
24.8 miles as the run from--
well, let me go on
with the full story.
So Pheidippides gets to Sparta.
He says to the Spartans, were
being invaded by the Persians.
We need your help.
The Spartans said, that's fine.
We'll come to your aid.
Except, we can't leave,
because the moon is not full.
And our religion forbids
us from leaving for battle
until there's a full moon.
That won't be for
another six days' time.
So now, Pheidippides is
sitting there thinking, wow,
that's great.
They're coming.
But they're delayed by six days.
I've got to tell my
Athenian mates that
are waiting at Marathon that
the Spartans are on the way.
They're just going to take a
little bit longer to get there.
So what does he do?
He turns around and
dead-heads back.
He runs back to Marathon.
The battle is fought.
And then he ran the final--
this is my version--
then he ran the final
stretch into the Acropolis
to fall dead.
He deserved to
die at that point.
But that is-- again--
that's 24.8 miles.
Why is the legend not the
Spartathlon-- this 153 mile
round trip?
Well, if you look back into
history, in ancient Greece,
there was nothing
more noble than dying
in the cause of your countrymen
and serving your country--
fulfilling your mission.
And that last
stretch from Marathon
to the Acropolis, someone died.
And that was just the
most glorious story ever.
Someone running a 153
miles round trip-- well,
the guy is just a
hemerodromoi I mean,
that's what he
does for a living.
He's paid to do it.
Yeah, it was a crappy
day at the office.
But he just did his job.
He died at the end, though.
That is Greek.
But the marathon-- the modern
Olympic marathon that started--
the modern Olympics,
which began in 1896,
the marathon was
actually 24.8 miles.
The next subsequent couple
Olympics, the marathon
distance, was 24.8 miles.
Well, in 1908, the marathon came
to London for the summer games.
And the queen
wanted the marathon,
which was the marquee
event of the Olympics,
to finish in front
of the royal viewing
box on the Olympic track.
And that was a little bit
further than 24.8 miles.
That was 26.2 miles.
So she talked to
the King and said,
we have to change a couple
of things around here
with this race.
We've got to make it
a little bit longer.
And he, of course, said, well
that's going to be a problem.
These people have been
running for 24.8 miles.
Adding another 1.4 miles,
that's going to be a tough sell.
And she gave him one
of those looks that--
you men that have
wives, you know
a woman when she
gives you that look,
she gives you one of those.
And what do you do when
your partner gives you
a look like that?
You say, yes, darling.
Anything for you.
So the King issued a decree
forever changing the distance
of the marathon to 26.2 miles.
And the rest is history.
So I think that at
the London Marathon,
if you're an
anarchist, at 24.8, you
might as well just stop, right?
In that last four, I
just say, hail the King.
All hail the King.
We just ran that last four--
1.4.
But anyway, that's
the road to Sparta.
The story is much
more intricate.
It's much more personal.
It's a journey not
just about running,
but about finding out who I am.
And I think that's a
journey that all of you I
encourage to take--
to look back into your ancestry
and figure out what makes you,
you.
And that's kind of what
this book is about as well.
So the one thing I
will say is that I
spoke about a gentleman
that guided me through this.
I'm not a historian.
I can barely write my name
in the dirt with a stick.
So I'm not even an author.
But the gentleman who
guided me through this book
and the history, Dr.
Cartledge from Cambridge,
is here in the room.
So can you please, yeah--
PAUL CARTLEDGE: I
ran all the way.
DEAN KARNAZES: So
I think what we're
going to do is open
up some questions.
You can ask me questions
about my background
or any sort of
historical questions.
PAUL CARTLEDGE: That's
a lovely presentation.
DEAN KARNAZES: You'll answer
the historical questions.
PAUL CARTLEDGE: Of course.
Of course.
SPEAKER: OK, we
will need the mic.
So please wait for the mic.
Dr. Cartledge, you
will also need the mic.
So I will run a bit.
AUDIENCE: Couple of questions.
Do you follow any specific diet?
Or do you recommend any
specific diets for long runs?
And the second question.
I've heard that the Kenyan
people run quite a bit.
They perform great in the
tournaments, Olympics,
and things like that.
Is there anything to
do with the genes?
Or how do they do that?
DEAN KARNAZES: Yeah, so do
I follow a specific diet?
I'll tell you what not to eat
while running for 36 hours.
Figs.
I would train for six or
eight hours eating figs.
And it was just fine.
But when you run for 24 hours
eating figs, it's not so good.
Why do we eat figs?
Because to help our regularity.
Well, when you're
running for 36 hours,
you don't necessarily
want to be regular.
So I avoid fibrous foods.
I don't carbo load any more.
This idea of carbo loading used
to be very popular, where you
eat a lot of pasta and rice.
And it just left me the next
morning at the starting line
feeling very bloated.
So now I just stay to
a very simple diet.
I follow what's
called a paleo diet.
So I don't eat anything that's
refined or processed in a bag.
If you can't pull it from a
tree or dig it from the ground
or catch it with your
hands, I don't eat it.
I have a mentor, a guy by
the name of Jack Lalanne,
who was one of those
American fitness guys--
muscle guys.
And he said, if man
makes it, don't eat it.
And if it tastes
good, spit it out.
This guy sounds very Spartans
to me, I can go with that.
Yeah.
And as for the Kenyans,
I think there's
a number of things
that help the Kenyans.
One, they live at altitude.
So they're training at altitude.
They're from a
culture of runners.
So they're kind of
immersed in that.
They start at a very young age.
They also are very
driven, because if they
win a race like the
London Marathon,
that's more money
than 15 Kenyans will
make their entire lifetime.
And that's just one race.
So they're very
motivated in that
regard as well-- very hungry.
And good for them, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could I just ask,
is there not a South American
people that also--
not just an African one--
that does a lot of this
long distance running?
Am I right in that you
mentioned it in your book?
DEAN KARNAZES:
Yeah, well there's
a couple cultures that are
from long distance runners.
There's one in
the Copper Canyon,
which were Tarahumara Indians.
So there's a book
called "Born to Run."
Some of you-- so you know
about the Tarahumara Indians.
I went down and
visited these folks.
And it's the same thing.
They were just from
a culture of running.
I said to one guy, what's
your training like?
He said, well some days
I run 60 or 70 miles.
I said, that's incredible.
What do you do?
He's like, well I'm the mailman.
So it's kind of
culturally, yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, so what allows
you to trace the story
from Pheidippides
without the sources that
allow you to know,
OK, what happened
or what did not happen.
What do we know for sure?
DEAN KARNAZES:
Can you translate?
Because your accent is strong.
PAUL CARTLEDGE: I think
what the question was
what is the ultimate basis,
in terms of evidence,
for the run of--
I call him Philippides.
Dean calls him Pheidippides.
But comes to the same thing.
And it is ultimately
just a few lines--
one chapter of Herodotus.
And I thought you all ought
to know that this year is
Herodotus's 2,500th birthday.
If you believe he was
born in 484 BC/BCE,
why is 2017 the 2,500th
anniversary of his birth?
Can anybody help me with that?
Because if you add together 2017
and 484, you don't get 2,500.
You get 2,501.
Because there's no BC
naught or AD naught.
So you go from BC
one to AD-- or CE--
one.
And therefore, you take off--
anyway, that's beside the point.
Herodotus was traveling around
and talking to Spartans,
talking to Athenians.
He wasn't either a
Spartan or an Athenian.
He came from what's
today Turkey--
from Halicarnassus, Bodrum.
And in his day, he had been
born in the Persian Empire--
this empire that was
trying to conquer
mainland Greece to add to its
existing territory in Asia.
So he had a particular
personal interest.
You rightly called him
the father of history.
History in Greek means inquiry.
History is the result
of inquiry in English.
But in Greek, it's the
process of inquiry.
If you go to the Natural
History Museum in London,
that's the Museum of
the Inquiry into Nature.
It's not the result of inquiry.
It is the inquiry itself.
So he inquired, why
did the Greeks--
the few Greeks who could
agree amongst themselves
for long enough--
why did they win?
Why did they not get
wiped out, totally
conquered, so on and so on?
So it was partly logistics.
It was partly spirit.
And this is Dean's
main point, I think.
So there's this one chapter.
And he says, really, what Dean
has said-- that "Phillippides"
or Pheidippides, was a hemeron,
or hemerodromois, or dromois.
And there's a problem there.
What does that
mean, a day runner?
Does it mean that he
runs only in the day--
not at night?
And there are people who
think that ancient Greek day
runners did not run at
night, whereas Dean has
run three nights consecutively.
And certainly, everybody
on the Spartathlon
and indeed "Philippides,"
Pheidippides
had to run at night.
Now, was that because there was
a particularly good full moon?
Not possible.
It might be.
But nevertheless,
even that probably
wouldn't have
given enough light.
It is a really puzzling
thing how these guys
kept going over that terrain.
I've tried walking barefoot.
And the problem is prickles.
It's not just rocks.
It's the things that
grow on the rocks.
Damn painful.
But it's probably the case
that actually Pheidippides
from a very young age--
I imagine he comes from
a family of runners.
And as with all crafts,
if you start it,
you learn it from your dad.
Typically your dad because this
is a very male-dominated world.
You harden your feet so it has
a kind of carapace over it.
You don't actually feel with
your tendons the ground.
You've got this skin
carapace over your feet.
Anyway, all he says is he
arrived there on the second
day-- so more than 24
hours, we would say--
less than 48 hours.
And so the Spartathlon
averages it, gives you 36.
It's a notional figure.
And that's really all he says
apart from one detail, which
is very ancient Greek--
that at some point on
his run, Pheidippides,
"Philippides" met a very
strange creature-- a being.
And not entirely human--
partly goat, partly
horse, partly human.
So human down to here, goaty
legs, and a horse's tail.
And his name was Pan or Pan--
it's a long A in Greek.
And that's where
we get panic from.
So if Pan is on your side, he
instills panic into the enemy.
And so he addressed Philippides.
And Philippides asked
him, what's going on?
And Pan says, you Athenians.
You don't worship me yet.
He came from Arcadia.
And he was worshiped
as a god in Arcadia.
He's the son of Hermes,
who's the messenger god.
So he's a very useful
god for travel.
Anyways, Philippides
obviously gets back to Athens,
they win the battle of Marathon.
And this is fact.
They indeed instituted a
cult under the Acropolis
and a rural shrine.
So it's not just
Herodotus making it up--
what a story.
Philippides must
have been bonkers.
But we then ask, don't we?
Have you heard of
the third man effect?
Does that phrase mean--
you're running, and you
imagine you see someone.
Or, if you're an ancient
Greek, you project it as a god.
And you project it
in Arcadia as Pan.
Did he really have a vision?
Was he hallucinating?
Did he really believe
that he saw Pan?
So that's just--
DEAN KARNAZES: He's
giving away all the book.
PAUL CARTLEDGE: You've
got to read the book.
SPEAKER: Maybe you just ask
a question and one of you
repeats it so--
DEAN KARNAZES: Yeah,
we'll just paraphrase.
Sure, that's fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can just speak.
AUDIENCE: Since you mentioned--
well, two questions.
Since you did run a
marathon barefoot,
you mentioned [INAUDIBLE]
tribe, just curious
what are your thoughts
about barefoot running
in general with regards to,
I guess, human physiology
and what makes sense
biomechanically
with modern shoe
technology [INAUDIBLE]
whether that's
serving us or not?
And second question--
what's next?
What's your next [INAUDIBLE]?
DEAN KARNAZES: Well
the first question,
we were talking about running
barefoot or wearing shoes
that are over-built. A
lot of shoes, I think,
are over-built with structure
and so forth versus running
in a more natural-feeling shoe.
And I've always thought
that barefoot running
was the way we were engineered
to run, as Paul said.
When I looked at
some of the runners
in the Tarahumara
Valley, the callus
on the bottom of their
feet were tremendous.
It looked almost like
an elephant foot.
I thought that's probably
why they've got that layer.
They're not feeling
as much as we do.
But I love to run barefoot
on the beach, on the sand,
or if there's a
nice grass field,
run barefoot on the grass.
And you'll see, you
alter your gait.
So when you run in
cushioned running shoes,
what you typically do is you
go to this heel strike pattern,
where you strike on your heel,
because there's a big EVA foam
pad there, and you
roll off to your toe.
What happens when
you run barefoot
is you run more either
on mid-foot or forefoot.
So you prance along.
So think if you're standing
on a block maybe this high.
And you're barefoot.
And you're going to jump off.
Would you land on your heel?
No.
You'd land on your
forefoot area.
And that's what it
feels like when you run.
And to me, that is the way
we are engineered to run.
It's a much more
natural feeling.
We tend to take shorter,
choppier foot strides.
So we alter our gait
in that regard as well.
And we accentuate our arm swing.
So quicker arm
swing, quicker steps.
Yeah.
What's next?
Well, I'm hoping
to run a marathon--
I once ran 50 marathons in
all of the 50 United States
in 50 consecutive days.
And I thought-- do you feel like
running a marathon right now?
Yeah.
PAUL CARTLEDGE: And Hawaii
is a little distance
from the mainland of the states.
DEAN KARNAZES: I swam there.
PAUL CARTLEDGE:
You swam to Hawaii.
And then you ran there.
DEAN KARNAZES: I thought that
was the ultimate road trip.
So I want to take that same
footprint, just globally,
and try to run a
marathon in every country
of the world in one year.
So that's my plan-- is to
set on a global expedition
and run a marathon in
every single country.
It sounds like the
ultimate road trip to me.
Uh huh?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So given that you've
accomplished many times
over something that many of
us will never even attempt
to accomplish, I
think you probably
have a really interesting
perspective on what is possible
versus what is not possible.
So, one, could you share,
maybe, some of that perspective,
in terms of how you
think of overcoming
challenges that maybe the
average person would find
really difficult to overcome.
And two, does everything else
in your life seem really easy?
[LAUGHTER]
DEAN KARNAZES: Well, the first
time I heard of someone run--
when someone said I'm
going to run 100 miles,
I couldn't get my
head around it.
I though, how many
days does it take?
Where are the camp grounds?
Where are the hotels?
And he said no.
The starting gun goes off
just like at the marathon.
And 100 miles later, you
get to the finish line.
That's how you finish the race.
And it was such an expansive
idea to me, I thought.
I don't even like
driving 100 miles.
How can a human run 100 miles?
That's impossible.
And then I went out and did it.
And I learned that
a lot of barriers
are self-constructed-- at least
physical barriers, for me.
They're just barriers that
I've put in my own mind.
If someone had
said to me, the man
five years before the
man ran 100 miles,
could you possibly
run 100 miles?
I would say no.
I'm incapable of that.
That'd be completely out of
the realm of possibility.
And then I went and did it.
And I thought, wow,
that was amazing.
And it proved to me I was better
than what I thought I was.
And I could go further than
what I thought I could.
And I think that lesson
translates into everything
with life.
You can apply that to
education, to your career,
to interpersonal relationships.
You learn that a lot of things--
the barriers you
put in front of you
are just things
that don't really
exist-- that you've just
conceived them yourself.
Does that kind of
address your-- yeah, OK.
Have you ever run a marathon?
AUDIENCE: No, only a half.
I don't think I'll come to full.
DEAN KARNAZES: Well
I'll tell you what.
The person that finishes
that full marathon will
be a different person
than the one that
stood at the starting line
that morning before the gun
went off.
You learn more about yourself
through hardship and struggle
and adversity than you
do through comfort.
Uh huh?
AUDIENCE: Do you follow a
training plan beyond running?
Like do you run to
train for running?
Or do you also do a whole
bunch of extra cross training
or something?
Like how do [INAUDIBLE]
what you do?
DEAN KARNAZES: Well, I don't
do something most of you
are doing right now.
I never sit down.
So my entire-- sorry.
My entire office has been
converted to standing level.
It's been that way for
about the last 15 years.
So I do all my writing, all my
emails, and everything standing
up--
typically barefoot,
and typically
bouncing around on my toes.
I have a pull-up bar in my
office and a sit-up mat.
And throughout the course
of the day, I have this--
what's called HIIT training--
High Intensity
Interval Training.
So they're sets of push
ups, pull ups, dips,
and something called burpees.
So it's about a 12
to 15 minute routine.
Your heart rate is very
elevated the entire time.
And I'll do, maybe,
four or five of those
throughout the course of
the day along with running.
Yeah.
And when I'm in a training
block, I'll get up early--
maybe 3:30 in the
morning-- and I
like to try to run a
marathon before breakfast.
And so run a marathon,
and then go to work,
do the HIIT training
throughout the day,
and then do a shorter--
maybe 10 or 12 mile
run-- in the afternoon,
like a tempo run or pace
run or hill repeats.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: That's amazing.
PAUL CARTLEDGE: Go to
work on a marathon.
AUDIENCE: What do
you think about while
running for such long times?
And how do you keep
yourself motivated?
DEAN KARNAZES: So what do you
think about while running,
and how do you stay motivated?
Running, I think
about a lot of things.
And I think about nothing.
The one thing I
like about running
is I'm a very strong introvert.
And when I'm running,
I can just kind of
put the world in
perspective and kind of
be alone with
myself for a while,
just to work things
through and to think.
I also listen to audio books.
So I've got about 500
audio books on my playlist.
I listen to probably two
or three books a week
just while I'm running.
Yeah.
And how do I stay motivated?
I always take on new challenges.
So if I told you what I've
done in the last month,
I've run a marathon
every single weekend
on three different
continents in the last month.
I fly from here to
Lisbon, Portugal.
I'm going to run.
And then on Saturday, I
fly to Washington, DC.
I've got a 50 mile run.
That night, I'm taking
a red-eye to California.
And I have the Big Sur
Marathon on Sunday.
So, I love my craft.
I love what I do.
I get to see the world.
And that keeps me motivated.
But it's a very
different reality
than someone living in London
with a day job training,
especially in the winter.
And that's why I
don't live in London.
I don't know how you do it.
[LAUGHTER]
Respect.
AUDIENCE: How do you recover?
Or do you actually
let your body recover?
DEAN KARNAZES: Recovery
is overrated, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't stretch.
I don't get massages.
I don't use a foam roller.
Yeah.
I guess which recovery
is kind of relative.
When I'm flying, I can't
think about recovery.
Because I'm flying so much.
It's
The finish line for me is
still another three weeks away.
Because I've got the
same sort of schedule
for three more weeks.
And then I'll rest
for a day or two.
AUDIENCE: Why all the running?
DEAN KARNAZES: Well, you saw
where my ancestors come from.
Maybe I'm just a
modern-day hemerodromoi.
PAUL CARTLEDGE: Tell them about
Ikaria on your mother's side,
because they might
not know about that.
DEAN KARNAZES: Does anyone
know about the Blue Zones?
The Blue Zones are these
areas of the world where
the indigenous
population lived to be
the oldest and the healthiest.
And my father is from mainland
Greece, the Peloponnese
Arcadia.
PAUL CARTLEDGE:
Where Pan came from.
DEAN KARNAZES:
Yeah, pandemonium.
PAUL CARTLEDGE: Pandemonium.
DEAN KARNAZES: And my mother is
from this island called Ikaria,
which is where Icarus--
the guy with the waxwings--
crash landed-- the boy.
And in Ikaria, they
have more centenarians
in any place on Earth-- so more
people that lived to be 100.
And I've been there
a couple of times.
And I've gone up into these
villages up in the mountains.
And these people are amazing.
I remember speaking
to this woman.
She was 104 years old.
And she was an entrepreneur.
But she was very disappointed.
And I said, what's the matter?
She said, well, I walked
three miles down to the bank
to get a loan to
build my business.
And the bank said, we're sorry.
We have a policy.
We don't loan money
to people over 103.
[LAUGHTER]
So I walk three miles
back up to my house.
And now I have no money.
SPEAKER: I think
we are out of time.
We are out of time.
So thank you all for coming.
If you want your book signed,
please come to the front.
And thank you very
much, Dean Karnazes.
DEAN KARNAZES:
And Dr. Cartledge.
[APPLAUSE]